NAZMUL IDRIS: Hi everyone.
I'm Nazmul.
I'm a developer.
IZABEL IDRIS: And
hi, everyone.
I'm Izabel.
I'm a designer.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Welcome to UX
Design For Developers.
You may recognize us from I/O
'13 where we did the design
lab which got a lot
of great feedback.
That confirmed that there's
a great demand for design
content from the developer
community.
This is why we're starting this
GDL series on design.
And over the coming months we're
planning on bringing you
some great content on the design
process, on mobile
design, platform design.
And we're planning on having
some great guests
on the show as well.
This show is really for design
minded developers who want to
learn how to use user centric
design to build products that
deliver a great user experience
and that are not
just a random collection
of features.
Before we get started I just
wanted to mention that we will
not be focusing on UI
elements, design
guidelines, and APIs.
Instead we will focus purely
on user experience.
So I wanted to set the stage
and talk briefly about why
it's important for developers
like us to engage in the
design process.
We really need to think about
building products rather than
just focusing on delivering
features
on a release schedule.
As developers, we understand
what it means to have velocity
in implementing feature
requests.
However, we rarely get to see
how our final products are
used by real people
in the real world.
And all too often we don't see
our contribution to the final
product at all.
You might think that if you
don't write front end or UI
code that you don't impact
the user experience for
product in any way.
But UI and UX are
not the same.
For example, when you compose an
email in Gmail for Android
and you don't have network
access, Gmail allows you to do
this anyway.
What Gmail does not do when you
press the send button is
notify you that you don't have
network access and that you
should try a different radio.
This is a great example of how
good user experience is
delivered by Gmail without
any UI whatsoever.
So, again, UI and UX
are not the same.
UI has to do with visual
layouts, colors, themes,
animations, and widgets.
While UI is important for user
interaction, it is not the
only thing that's interacting
with the user.
The visual and non visual code
comes together to deliver the
overall user experience.
So good user experience is about
removing annoyances,
needless distraction, and
friction so that end users can
accomplish their tasks
with ease and grace.
Google Now is a great example
of this in action.
It's unobtrusive.
It does everything it needs
to in the background.
And the UI is very minimal.
Google Now delivers unexpected
delight by pleasantly
surprising you with relevant
information just
when you need it.
We should own the unexpected
delight that users feel.
We should also take
responsibility
for delivering it.
The products that we build
can make people happy.
So since the smartphone
revolution happened a few
years ago, everything
has changed.
Users have expectations of a
certain level of fit and
finish, innovation and quality
that comes from something
Google, Apple, or Microsoft
would put in their products.
So as a third party developer,
meaning that you're not in the
core Android or iOS or Windows
platform teams, your job is
now harder because the quality
of first party apps keeps
getting better and better.
So how do you stay relevant?
How do you get people to use
your apps and not just install
and forget them or just ignore
them altogether?
If you want a chance at success
it's crucial for you
to keep the end user in mind
and to create a compelling
user experience for them.
Now I'm going to show
you some examples of
good UI and bad UX.
This will help you further
disambiguate
one from the other.
We can all agree that user
account creation and login or
the bane of our existence.
When was the last time you
looked forward to creating yet
another account on a
website you may or
may not visit again?
So let's take a second to
admire this nice account
creation form.
Now, as a developer you're
probably thinking, I made it
validate all the fields, it's
mobile friendly, the form has
a great UI.
It's legible.
It's got lots of padding.
And it's nicely laid out.
But this is probably what
your user's thinking.
I just tried a demo of your
product and it's exactly what
I've been looking for.
I wanted to get the full
version right now.
So why am I being punished by
having to fill out this
massive form?
So how do you resolve this?
The right way to do this, of
course, is to use something
like G+ sign in so your users
can create an account in a
matter of seconds.
By removing friction from the
login process, you can make
sure that you're not getting in
the way of gaining another
user for your product.
So here's another example.
Online shopping is another
thing that we all do.
And here's a check out flow
that everyone should be
familiar with.
Just take a second to admire
the length of these forms.
There's a lot of information
for a user to fill out.
Now, as a developer you might
be thinking, I've collected
all the data I need in order to
make the API calls to the
fulfillment and payment
back ends.
And from a UI perspective
it's a great form.
Lots of detailed information has
to be collected and it's
pretty clearly layed out.
Now, this is probably what
your user's thinking.
I spent a lot of
time and effort
adding stuff to my cart.
And I'm trying to spend a lot
of money on your website.
But had I known I'd have to do
all this paperwork, I would
have probably not used
this website.
But since I'm already vested,
why do I feel like checking
out is as painful as
doing my taxes?
So how do we result this?
One way to do it is to use
Google Wallet so that your
users can pay for their stuff
in a matter of seconds.
By removing friction from the
all important checkout flow,
which is essentially where
you're getting paid, your
user's more likely to
come back and buy
more stuff from you.
So here are a few more best
practices that you should
consider in order to deliver
the best possible UX in the
products that you're
working on.
On mobile devices the
quality of network
connectivity varies greatly.
So it makes sense to think about
what your application
can do in offline mode.
For example, Gmail on Android
allows you work offline and
you can view your downloaded
emails and compose new ones.
Once network connectivity is
restored, Gmail silently syncs
everything without notifying
or bugging the user.
Now, the user's attention span
is also a precious resource.
So we should use it wisely.
Design applications so that if
the user is distracted in any
moment, they can return
to your application
without much friction.
A great example, again,
is Gmail.
It continuously saves emails in
the background when you're
composing them so if you leave
the app for any reason you'll
never lose any work.
If your app is loading a lot
of data, you might consider
pre fetching chunks of it that
might be needed soon.
This way the data will be ready
when the user needs it
and there's no lag or delay in
the user experience as they
move forward.
Similarly, for any data you
might have already fetched,
it's a good idea to cache it
for some period of time in
case that the user wants go
back to it, that way there
won't be any lag or delay
when the user goes back.
I'm going to hand it
off to Izabel now.
IZABEL IDRIS: All right.
Now we're going to
talk a little bit
about the design process.
So Nazmul's covered some
best practices.
So let's talk about how we can
actually create amazing user
experiences that delight
our users.
So how do you go about
doing this?
Well, by using the user centric
design process.
So what is this user centric
design process?
Well, I'm going to give you a
brief overview of the process,
which has been adapted
for developers.
First off, the design process
begins with user research.
So user researchers go out in
the world and they get a sense
for what users expect from
technology and a sense of
their frustrations when these
current expectations aren't
met by current products
they're using.
They also give you insights into
what your users want, and
they gather data from real
people and define things
called personas and use cases.
So a persona is a made up user
whose attributes represent
those of a larger group
of real people.
So they're used as a conceptual
model to drive the
design and the functionality
of a product.
They're also used as a way to
communicate and prioritize
feature requests amongst PMs,
designers, and developers.
So it's really important to
understand who your user is
and what makes them tick.
So your product can't satisfy
everyone all the time.
So you need to design for
specific personas and keep
those in mind.
So use cases, they describe an
interaction between a persona
and your product.
And they describe when, where,
and how a persona actually
uses the features
of your product.
So as developers, we
usually think of
features as bits of code.
However, real users, they don't
really see it that way.
So they use a set of features to
accomplish a task within a
specific physical environment.
So thinking of features in
terms of use cases and
personas is a really good habit
for us to get into.
So as developers, we're all
familiar with features.
But how do they fit in
the context of a
persona and a use case?
So to answer this, let's
consider a feature in the
Gmail Android app, which allows
users to send emails in
offline mode when there's
no network.
So lets picture a user named
George, who's constantly up in
the air traveling and spends
a lot of time at airports.
So while he's at the airport,
Georges is using Gmail for
Android on his smartphone.
And he's doing lots of other
important things.
And, of course, being at the
airport, he doesn't have good
network coverage.
So if the implementation of
offline mode requires Georgia,
a busy traveler, to make IT
decisions while he's at the
airport then it would
be an epic fail.
So George doesn't have any
patience or bandwidth to deal
with IT issues about how an app
should behave in online
versus offline mode.
So what Gmail for Android does
is, it implements these
features without any
UI whatsoever.
So in fact it actually hides
from George whether it's in
online or offline mode.
So the Gmail for Android is
actually a great example of
how a feature, which is composed
without network, que
for delivery, and send when
network is available has been
implemented really well for our
persona George, the busy
traveler, and his use case,
which is sending an email
while at an airport with
a crappy network.
So now we know that for personas
are important.
Let's look at how
they're created.
So user researchers will gather
a lot of data from real
people by asking them targeted
questions and also by
observing them using certain
technologies or products.
Then user researchers will
categorize these users into
groups based on their similar
attributes driven by data.
So then they give this group a
name and a persona is born,
such as Casey Googler
or Darth Storm.
So a persona is a target user
for whom your UX is going to
be optimized moving forwards.
So here are some things
to keep in mind.
You don't have to denature your
persona by compositing
incompatible attributes
into one persona.
So for example, you can't have
a persona who is a coupon
clipping bargain shopper and
who's also a foodie that
doesn't care about price.
Another example is you can't
have a persona who has joined
the dark side but also
uses the force.
So be careful that your design
doesn't attempt to support too
many personas that are unrelated
because it's going
to be impossible to
build a product
that satisfies everybody.
So for example, you wouldn't
want to design a car that
targets the following personas,
race car drivers and
soccer moms and grandmothers.
This would be a confused car.
NAZMUL IDRIS: [INAUDIBLE]
that car.
IZABEL IDRIS: So once you've
decided which personas your
product is going to support,
it's really important to think
about use cases or, basically,
how your personas are going to
use your product in
the real world.
So let's say for example your
product is an app that allows
you to order pizza using
your smartphone.
So let's say our persona, Casey
Googler, she might use
your app in the following
ways.
So her kids are hungry
and screaming and
they need food ASAP.
Or maybe she's working late and
she doesn't have time to
make dinner and so she needs
food really fast.
Or maybe it's on the weekend
and she's watching the game
with her friends and they all
want to order some food.
So these are some cases
Casey might have.
So a good app that supports the
use case of the kids are
hungry, she'd have a quick way
to order family combo meals.
And this would include a
combination of best selling
pizzas, kids menu items,
drinks, and
deserts all in one.
So this feature will make
Casey's life really easy at
this stressful time.
So Casey's going to really
appreciate the fact that
you've considered this scenario
in her life when her
kids are screaming at dinner
time and she's using your apps
to order food.
So you will have delivered a
moment of delight for Casey.
So this is a really good
example of an app whose
feature set is driven by
personas and their use cases.
So personas and use cases,
they go hand in hand.
And they provide a human
context for features.
So as developers, we're used
to seeing feature lists.
But we never really put a face
to Casey Googler and we can't
really understand her pain and
what she's going through when
she's using your application.
So when her kids are hungry and
screaming, as a developer
we don't really understand
that.
So the design process really
brings us closer to our users.
And this is really the only
way that we can build apps
that people love to use.
So you're probably asking where
do we as developers fit
in the process?
So we tend to think of design as
the domain of the designer.
And we just write code to
their design specs.
So, unfortunately, this is most
often the case today.
But it really shouldn't be.
So as developers, you can make
sure that designs are grounded
in reality.
So through our deep knowledge
and understanding of
technology, we can make sure
that technological constraints
aren't violated.
So even designers create
something amazing that
challenges the status-quo and
breaks new ground, it's not
going to build itself.
So as developers, we bring
great designs to life.
And it's our job as developers
to be inspired by the new
designs and come up with
innovative ways to build
software to delight our users.
So effective collaboration
between teams is really
crucial to the design process.
So personas help foster
effective communication
between different teams
throughout the product
development life cycle by
removing confusion about who
our user actually is.
And so under tight deadlines--
and we're all used to this--
teams can use personas to
validate decisions about which
features to cut or
keep and how to
prioritize those features.
So ideally initial design
should be turned into
prototypes that are
tested by real
users as soon as possible.
So I'm going to hand it off to
Nazmul right now to talk about
a design activity that
you guys can do.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Thanks, Izabel.
So we've heard a lot about
the design process.
And so we just wanted to talk
about how you can actually
follow this process to design
an application.
Let's say that you wanted to
build an application that you
could use to order
pizza online.
So we're not actually going to
build this application or
design it right now.
But we will talk through the
steps that you would take if
you were to design this app.
So now, again, the purpose of
this application that we're
designing is to allow users to
order pizza from a single
pizza parlor.
So it's not, like, seamless.
Now as developers, when we see
this slide our instinct is to
start thinking about
coding and APIs.
Instead of thinking about how
we're going to code this up,
let's do something
different today.
Let's think about why we're
building this application.
We want to be a service
to people who
are hungry for pizza.
We want them to get exactly what
they want by using the
application.
And we want them to
feel delighted to
have used the app.
We also want them to tell
their friends about it.
So this sounds like marketing,
but this is actually the
result of a good user
experience.
It's important for us as
developers to stay connected
to what we're trying to
accomplish here, which is to
use technology to create
compelling experiences in the
service of user.
This is a message that often
gets lost in the rush to get
features implemented and
released out the door ASAP.
So let's think about the persona
and use case that we
will design for.
So now imagine the perfect
pizza application.
What would it look like?
How would people use it?
When, where, and how would
people use it?
So think about the people and
use cases that you're going to
optimize the user
experience for?
Then let's think about building
a flow that your
users will follow so they
can go from being
hungry to being satisfied.
The flow of screens should
support the list of features
that neatly fit in the context
provided by your personas and
your use cases.
So let's think about how
we would even define an
application's persona.
So it's very important to keep
these personas handy, by the
way, so even after you've
created them you can always
reference them later on as you
design and even implement your
application.
So in order to create
personas let's
think about a few questions.
So here's just a few questions
that you might think about to
help identify attributes that
help define this person.
So, for example, in the context
of pizza do they value
convenience over price or do
they bargain shop and are only
concerned with price?
Do they have a credit card?
Do they use Paypal
or Google Wallet?
The answers to these questions
will determine what
technologies you use
in the application.
Do they have dietary
restrictions?
And, again, this will affect
the types of menus that you
display, not user interface
menus but actual food menus.
Do they shop online often?
Do they primarily do this using
a smartphone or a laptop
or a tablet?
So, for example, this can help
you differentiate the design
for your smartphone application
from your tablet
application.
So on the smartphone it's
more actionable.
The user experience should be
more actionable where they can
place an order and
go pick it up.
On a tablet it might be more
research oriented where
they're considering what to
eat and then they can just
place the order.
And, finally, are they
comfortable or willing to
share sensitive information with
your application, things
like credit card information
and personal information?
So now let's talk about the flow
that your persona will go
through in order to
go from being
hungry to being satisfied.
It's important to think about
the flow or path that your
users will take through your
application and the steps that
they will need to complete even
before you think about
sketching out the designs.
And the sketching has to happen
before implementation.
So the first step is
they're hungry.
This is the main thing
motivating the user.
The want some food.
In this case it's pizza.
So the second step in this flow
should be where they can
create an order.
They might have dietary
restrictions.
If we take this into account in
our design, it would be an
opportunity to deliver delight
to that persona.
And they should also decide when
and where the food will
be delivered.
So the third step is
very important.
They've figured out what they
want to eat, and now they want
to complete the order
by paying.
And this is a great opportunity,
again, to deliver
delight to the user by making
sure that this payment step is
super easy.
Finally, once the user is paid,
they're now owed a pizza.
They have an expectation of
when the food will arrive.
And the application should
ideally provide them with
accurate status information
so they're aware of
what's going on.
For example, is the pizza
being cooked?
Is it out for delivery?
Or perhaps the driver can't
enter the property.
Now, this is a great
opportunity, again, to deliver
delight by giving them the
information they need without
inundating them with minute
status updates.
So once you have your personas
figured out and then you have
an idea of the flow,
now you can think
sketching out your design.
So it doesn't have
to be high tech.
You can just use index cards,
post it notes, or
just sheets of paper.
Make sure, though, that you
focus on the flow of the
application and not just the
user interface of every
individual screen.
So we want to think about this
thing as a collection of
screens, not just one screen or
just a pile of screens that
aren't really connected.
Now, once you've done the
initial design, you've
sketched it out on paper, go
ahead and put these papers up
on a wall to depict the flow
that a user would take through
your application.
It's important to get feedback
on this flow from other people
early in the process.
It's essential to
test out designs
before you begin coding.
Now, if possible, try to create
a simple interactive
prototype using something like
PowerPoint or Keynote.
You can also use something
like Fluid UI to actually
create designs that you can
put on your smartphone and
have a more realistic rendering
of your designs
Now this is an iterative
process, so don't be afraid to
make mistakes and make big
changes or even start over.
This is the time when you want
to make changes and test
assumptions.
It's way cheaper to do this at
this stage than have to modify
code later on when you're, let's
say, your application
has been released.
Now, we all make assumptions
about what experience is best
for our users.
We all have gut instincts, or
we have a feeling that this
would work great for us
or someone like us
or someone we know.
But unless we test these
assumptions by allowing actual
users to interact with
prototypes, we can make some
really costly errors that will
only show themselves after the
app has been built and people
actually start to use it.
So to wrap up, designing great
products that delight users is
what it's all about.
Great design is not just
the job of designers.
It's got to be a joint
effort by developers,
designers, and PM.
In the future we see developers
becoming more
design savvy and designers
implementation savvy.
It's essential that we
understand how the design
process works and how we
fit in that story.
With our understanding of
technology, we as developers
can ground designs in reality
and we can also bring great
designs to life.
Now, think product, not screens
or just features.
Your product is being used by
real people, and you should
never lose sight of this.
Don't get bogged down in feature
lists and also being
in the service only of
release schedules.
IZABEL IDRIS: So it's really
important that we design for
personas and use cases.
So we need to throw out personas
that don't fit.
And we can't design
for every one.
So we need to throw out needless
features, personas,
and use cases that might hinder
our user experience.
Saying no to the wrong thing
is equally as important as
saying yes to the right thing.
So personas help us understand
who is using our products.
And use cases help us understand
when, where, and
how they're using
our products.
do not try and satisfy everyone
or you'll end up
satisfying no one.
We need to become a part of
the design story because
design should be everyone's
responsibility.
We should own the unexpected
delight that our users feel
when they use the amazing
products that
we build for them.
We need to take ownership of
delivering this delight.
So we hope that this episode
will be the start of your
journey into the world of design
driven development.
We didn't cover everything
in this episode.
This is just the beginning.
We're planning to do
a show every month.
And so please join us on our
G+ community so that we can
travel on this journey together
and keep this
conversation going.
There's going to be links in the
bottom in the description
of this YouTube video where you
can find out where this G+
community is.
And, again, we hope to
see you next month.
And until then remember,
design is everyone's
responsibility.